So how do we make this BTB realistic? It needs to be small yet
it needs to work this way. First of all we don't need to have an entry for
every possible PC. It's enough if we have enough entries for
all the instructions that are likely to execute soon. So for
example if our program is executing a loop that has about a hundred instructions
of code we really need only slightly more than a 100 entries. After the first
iteration of the loop the BTB will be populated with instructions in the loop,
at which point we will keep finding what we need in the BTB. So
now we have relatively few entries in the BTB. Let's say that we do our timing
experiments and we find that only 1,024 entries can be accessed in one cycle.
The question is now, there are many, many possible PCs. How do we map each PC
to an entry in a way that avoids conflicts among different PCs that map to
the same entry? And note also that we need this mapping function to be really,
really simple because any delay in computing the mapping function means that we
need an even smaller BTB so that the whole thing finishes in one cycle.
The way we do this is the program counter from which we are fetching,
is let's say is 64 bit to byte. So it has bits starting from zero, to 63.
We need 10 bits to index into our BTB. So what we will do is we'll take
the least significant ten bits and use that as the index into our BTB.
This mapping function is really fast because we do is we
just take things ten bits and we just feed that to the BTB as an index.
Why are we using the least significant bits and not the most significant bits?
Think about the typical program where an instruction has some sort of PC address
and then the next instruction will have an address that is very close to it.
For example, just increment by four and so on.
So if we were using the most significant bits of the PC, all instructions that
are in the same part of the program would map to the same entry.
because they have the same most significant bits. Thus, if you have a loop of
some sort here, all of the instructions in the loop would map to the same entry,
so that as we execute this loop, these instructions are kicking each
other's stuff from the BTB, which we don't want to have. We want each of
these to have an entry. If we use the least significant bits, what we get
is that each instruction gets a different entry from nearby instructions, thus
ensuring that things like loops and functions and so on neatly map to the BTB.